you're sending money there to protect
Ukraine's border when we got the
situation we have on our border just in
the last hour by the way uh Donald Trump
has endorsed Jim Jordan I've had Jim
Jordan on the show many times I think
he's a good guy he's great on free
speech and the tech stuff especially he
doesn't want to fund Ukraine here's a
little uh video of Jim Jordan yesterday
talking about what his policy would be
related to Ukraine well let's talk a
little bit about aid for Ukraine because
there are number of conservatives who
say in your conference that they will
syn any candidate for speaker who does
support aid for Ukraine so where are you
on that I've been clear all along why
should we be sending American tax
dollars to Ukraine when we don't even
know what the goal is no one can tell me
what the objective is is it is it some
kind of negotiated peace is it driving
them out of the eastern Ukraine is it
driving them out of Crimea which they've
had for 10 years now that they took
during the Obama Administration what is
the objective and so until you can tell
me the goal I don't think we should
continue to send money there
particularly when we have the problems
we have on our border so that's
fundamental
I just think that's front and center and
then second how is the money that's
already been sent how is it how has it
been spent right what kind of waste is
going those are two fundamental
questions that I think the American
taxpayers want to know the answers to
before they send any more of their
hard-earned money there particularly
you're sending money there to protect
Ukraine's border when we got the
situation we have on our border so those
are the fundamental questions that we
should get answered before we even think
about sending more money Libby sometimes
it's find it's hard to find white pills
these days but that's seems like a white
pill to me like if we end up with him as
the speaker like that seems pretty solid
right yeah you know I thoroughly agree
on that Jordan was one of the names
floated during that epic speaker fight
in January uh he was nominated a couple
of times I think even Matt Gates
nominated him a couple of times along
with Byron Donalds and Donald Trump and
you know his pet cat or whatever else
but um yeah I think I think Jordan is
actually a pretty standup guy which is
rare for a politician and I appreciate
his integrity on wanting to know where
the money in Ukraine has already been
spent and what the plan is for getting
out of this situation we hear bid and
repeatedly say we're in it for as long
as it takes but we don't know as long as
it takes to what and I think that that's
clearly so important you also had uh the
House and Senate I believe both vote
against um an audit for what happened to
the money so far we see Ukraine which is
a country that is known for decades to
be a very corrupt Nation we see um
defense ministers getting fired and we
see consistent Staffing changes we see
zalinski actually putting in prison one
of the guys who funded not only his
acting career but his political career
and now he's going after him he's the
big bad oligarch you know probably
because he got all the money he could
out of that guy so it's time to get rid
of him um we don't know where the money
is going in Ukraine we don't know what
the plan is for this war we do know that
the Pentagon reached out to Congress and
said that they're going to have trouble
trouble replacing the weapons they have
already sent to Ukraine Biden has
repeatedly promised no tanks no f-16s no
uh Rockets you know no long range
missiles um these things these promises
have consistently been broken we don't
know what else is going to be broken
there's in fact only one promise left
that Biden has made that he hasn't
broken with regard to the war in Ukraine
and that's that we won't be going to war
with Russia so if we continue on this
course we can expect Biden to break that
promise as well and before we know it
we're going to have an underfunded
military situation here at home with our
own troops we're going to be continuing
to pour money into Ukraine and we're
going to have our border completely
decimated and our nation
overruns